getting to you know reunited with the
cast and crew well it's been incredible
I mean we really just picked up where we
left off more or less it's so weird
because it just feels like we were away
for the weekend doesn't really oh my god
completely at the same time it feels
like a miracle has occurred you know
like both of those things are kind of
happening simultaneously but no it feels
the same because I well I don't know why
but we do have not only obviously the
same cast but same directors same
costume designers same hair and makeup
people same same everybody mean it's
probably 75% of the people working on
the show we're working on it eleven and
a half years ago Wow
it were just happen to be that machine
serendipitous available yeah yeah how
could that be I know what about yourself
over the course of 11 years how did you
kind of evolve as an as an actress well
I had a pretty serious heroin addiction
yeah I had a kick so that's kind I'm
filled up a lot of my free time so yeah
that's it's tough yeah
but they see quitting smoking is harder
so I guess I got off easy
never smoked you uh do you remember your
first you remember the first episode you
remember the pilot yes I do I remember
it quite well
we were we were getting ready to do an
audience run-through that's how Jimmy
Jimmy likes to test with an audience
run-through before he shoots the pilot
and we we were we went outside of the
soundstage and right across the street
there was a little commissary and we
were sitting at a table outside and this
is back in 1998 and Eric McCormack and
Debra Messing used to smoke cigarettes
and so they were having a cigarette and
Shawn and I were just sitting there and
this guy named Don ohlmeyer good friend
of AJ's
so that tells you a lot um he was some
NBC executive at the time and he comes
strolling down the lane in his like
three-piece you know pinstripe suit and
we were all like oh no and he comes over
to our table and we were like this is
unprecedented because you know that the
brass did not speak to the actors and he
comes over and Deborah has this unlit
cigarette because they run out of
matches and he's like oh here used my
lighter and he pulls out this slim chic
solid gold Cartier lighter and she's
like thanks and she lights her cigarette
and goes to give it back and he's like
keep it and we were like oh that is
getting picked that's an amazing story
and probably their accurate indication
of obviously what was gonna happen like
bought a Range Rover like oh it's on did
you find what about the voice for your
character because it's so distinct did
you find that voice right away
um I had that voice in mind but I
thought well they'll definitely fire me
if I do that right away at the beginning
because I'd had experiences and
compassed of doing crazy characters and
then having people you know just being
arrested you know like I would scare
people at auditions sometimes because
I've come in with these crazy big
characters and so I thought well I'll
just tone it down a little bit but the
tone of this show is very farcical it's
kind of like a musical comedy without
the music the pace and the energy and my
normal speaking voice although also
quite irritating is very laconic so I
just over the first like 10 episodes or
so it just got a little bit higher a
little bit higher and I just thought it
suited the pace of the show better but
also I thought it was funny that this
character who is so incredibly
judgmental of people who are perfectly
great and wearing perfectly beautiful
clothing and everything else
this quality that you can't escape from
that it's the most irritating thing on
the planet the writers for this show are
incredible
like the band the one-liners and the the
bench on this show is just it's it's
really great and really of the now you
guys have a ton of guest appearances in
the past are you looking forward to
anyone coming back and and have people
obviously express and reached out and
said I'd love to come on the show again
I think people have reached out yeah I
don't know who but I've heard you know
rumors but um I would like Alec Baldwin
to come back for sure because he's well
a he's great but I just loved working
with him and he's a great guy he's a
good storyteller and I was a character
but I'd love for him to come back and I
would love for Matt Damon to come back
it's probably a long shot but maybe not
right yeah that would be amazing and
we've got one of my dream people back
this week Molly Shannon so she's done
this will be I think her fourth episode
and I just love her she's a she's a
she's a friend of mine all my friends
are famous celebrities but she's just so
great and I just love her so much soon
is there any episodes that stand out I
mean when you reach when you reach the
kind of I guess notoriety and
recognition that this show has received
over the course of it being on is there
episodes that stand out that you like
you know that episodes on my favorites
mm-hmm yeah there are I mean I think
that audiences have their favorites and
so I never know like for me
for the first you know go around the
eight seasons we did there were so many
fun ones there was one where we some
Howard in a production of The Sound of
Music I don't know why that stands out I
guess because just cuz it was so
different but a lot of the you know slap
fights and things that I did with
Shawnee
but I feel like the episodes were doing
now some of the new ones like the one
that's airing tonight is one of the to
me for me a personal favorite and the
writers really gave me something to do
that was really incredible it really
allowed me to tell a story in a way that
I've never I've never had an opportunity
like that before in all my 93 years and
then the we shot an episode last night
that's a Christmas episode that's airing
in December that I think it's gonna be
really really cool I think the writers
are kind of breaking it open and they're
just getting more even more imaginative
and and also they're taking like certain
topics and you know the show that aired
a couple weeks ago about the the
conversion therapy camp for kids and
some interesting things that are coming
out so it's still really funny and then
there's a few episodes where there's a
poignancy also I need a birthday plan
you have a birthday coming up there yeah
any birthday plans I I thought you were
taking me somewhere for the weekend what
is that did you say yes because you
never texted me back yeah I I know I
thought that was what we do every year
um I didn't know like you took a place
and surprised me of course but this year
I didn't know because I haven't heard
back from you well yeah I mean I'm
planning I'm packed okay yes we are what
salon great yeah but don't tell me where
I like to be surprised okay